Війна війною, а худоба без кукурудзи взимку
не зможе, кажуть селяни Бахмутського району.
За сім кілометрів від лінії розмежування
люди збирають врожай, що лишився після фермерських комбайнів.
Ще півтора роки тому сюди долітали снаряди,
навколо були позиції військових, оточені мінними полями.
Утім схоже, зима і бідність
лякають людей більше, ніж міни.
Тут мін немає! Якщо були б,
то стояли б таблички «міни». Якщо комбайн косить,
чому нам на полі не збирати? Ми не ходимотуди,
де щось вибухало!
Більшість полів після відведення військ сапери перевірили,
кажуть у держслужбі з надзвичайних ситуацій.
Утім деякі фермери, що мають поля поблизу
лінії розмежування, нерідко викликають
спеціалістів для додаткової перевірки.
За селом Кленове позаминулого року трактор підірвався,
орали 6 січня.
Вибухнув трактор.
В нас поки все нормально.
В Бахмутському районі за останні два роки
на мінах загинули троє людей, один став інвалідом,
кажуть в держслужбі з надзвичайних ситуацій.
На 100% населення від мін поки не убезпечене,
хоча розмінуванням Донбасу займаються і цивільні сапери,
і військові, і міжнародні організації.
Лише держслужба з надзвичайних ситуацій в Донецькій області
з червня 2014 року очистила
понад двадцять одну тисячу гектарів
від ста тридцяти п’яти тисяч вибухонебезпечних предметів.
На четвертому році війни штаб АТО вже має
систематизовану мапу з мінними полями
і небезпечними ділянкам. За міжнародними стандартами,
ці території мають бути позначені на місцевості.
Як правило, ми установлюєм ці таблички.
І не только ми.
Бувають непоодинокі випадки,
коли все ж таки знаки ці пропадають.
Тож доводиться регулярно перевіряти, чи таблички на місці,
і за потреби, встановлювати нові.
Тим часом ЮНІСЕФ намагається пробудити
пильність дітлахів. За даними ООН,
лише цьогоріч від мін на Донбасі загинули троє дітей
і четверо постраждали.
Часто вибухівку маскують під предмети, які приваблюють дітей.
Якщо не ваше, не чипайте!
Хоч би це був сьомий айфон, проходимо повз!
Правила виживання у воєнні часи дітлахам і підліткам доносять
через мультфільми та комікси. Тренери відзначають,
інколи діти краще за дорослих усвідомлюють,
як поводитися в небезпечних ситуаціях.
Я спочатку огляну усе навколо себе,
щоб не було чогось ще поряд.
Відійду набезпечнувідстань у 25-30 метрів
і зателефоную на 101.
Такі тренінги вже пройшли понад 5000 дітей,
переважновселах. Адже саметут
найбільше страждають від мін, які залишає за собою
війна на Сході України.